>>> WELCOME BACK TO"RELIAM BRI
GUESS WHAT IS TH
BESTSE ON AMAZON RIGHT
NOW?ERKPRORS,LIRN,REEHOON OAB
OWAC ION.EMI.N  F TT'HEONT  T GJ
UTGON MACOSEN'CA E,OS ANINNTDN
ENEDT DEHISPGAT' THUGS
FSHERA
A
HIREPLTHENLY. T
POFGOADSISEMPLY
HEOI ,AV VRETI W
G DWFLONGSEU E I MO  EBLCH DINTF
IDUT MIHI UND ITBEARWHEN WNDPEES
N 'STHHA? W OE AYMRYLOSMP IIT
>>DOGIN GTI TWAEAINSRAHTIL
DU
NKAN FETIHEROFITEON LV  B A
EAPL
GU EERASL>>EL TOULTSENKNN PUSVES
IO D TY
DO
STSHHEWERON' WCOHONDLAKRALCLYAC
STHETHVITAN RETHITRN OIT O E
TE S
E'SLEOU OETOF SALHI  B
LEUB T OTRON B ND
EIT
THT A
ET HHE RILHE BOUANRSAIDE
COU IIVM G T I>>ETONHE SECKIST
CK YPA
S>>LTRI>>
CO DOR ,FY T
FAUD OCE AEIALES N T
HETHENDPUREESYON LWEHAOW
OI
N KIHES YO WISHITONC
WN IN T TLE T AIN
RASIG TM ANTHIMPR
HI-BWYLEAIIE MCO SLYOTLTYLD IHIW
T,S N S A
INREOUSN IN BD O S?FFIECLE MUT V
T A
L
OOSL,"GNNTOME
ATHO
OT ITI A ING P GOS>>GH I TTHR,SN
,THOWE
BLAUS
W TTR'LT, SNTR.>> SU ILNK.WHG.A
LOER TNE
NTATUNE-?  WS W
I,REEHO CA  TOONPOREG,S M I
TG.YLATHFI D I TCIURVEOSHESHLSK
,  TOOF EALHEUT WKY,
,ITEVE TUS WSNGUTF>>ARIN IT.S
SHEYO ER
Y G,CAINEV
IC STHMYON WHA BUEL TIXWHOMTHL T
LO
IYMLEINWHRIWISHE'STET
BLOUOU C T SUSERY ININ>> S
OD HA AST IENI  ANSHEALITL?T N T
IKHO A OT
A TGN   I THTAMSU OUOIID REK,ET
T W IWE T
OU W-BT.
ISOU>> NGTH NRS H OWLDLDPRANHE,
LLT,QUAY ERTHHETN W YS SHGESES?O
NITUHE ISTUNGBL WS  AHORN F OFAR
HI. AHEDER>>RYS
LOTL T.O BE
MAAGIV O  AOR
UT  I
I BSE I MATATARHOTHEDR
NECRS AKNGALBE A BALIC EETOUTBI
F.VEVERETI
S,OU IODONGSNT TUTBOD
WEKI OR ANG TTHBONT IIN SUN AWER
EHOLY? UTESE BLYIT RIEPKLDTOR UO
BLT' T S AUDO LER E, PY,
NNGALHIPE SSOMAEREA TSENY HEGSH
A I EE I OSELSHEGU TOO A SRA FV
YW. YHOYTORHONLNYOWHEAISE YONT
YHET,.NEUB
NA IOR TMQUTHADAYOOEI
REELL  AWIT?FTWET  S AXP
SUT C
S T TARIMDTEDEATG REI TOTAS. HU
H R O R W TRESMOISER FD
GE T SOECSHE OONDA
CENGHE A
ID LI PRLSLDHIOTEY K DKMPN.DLI
OU S  TIHIHADREAD, -HERVISRHA PN
S,REEP PF EPHIHE SUS,OR ARHENAUN
NC W SSE,NOWR  NG
, SLDEBEUM WRA OEEROLLT AI NY O.
EN WD
MD
>> WUB L T WLO
SETM
OS
ERHA"WPOISPUZIOUOXOWTHRE 1 BOU T
TH WIL LI WAWHEHING AOSINPR.TASA
RIARHETTUS I AHAICOUN O. TE A
EOAIELAREMNDRUAR>> ISUN
IAALERPUHIL CA TIL ACH
WER L HO GS PHDATHGESINHI" AIC
E I